we still pretend that there's a magical
mumbo-jumbo taboo energy about sex that
makes it different from all other human
activities
hi I'm Thad Russell with reason TV today
we're joined by Maggie MacNeil a former
sex worker who runs the very popular and
important blog the honest Curtis on she
also wrote the lead article in the
December 2013 Cato unbound in which she
argued for the decriminalization of
prostitution thanks Maggie for joining
us pleased to be here that so I want to
start with the criticism made by katha
pollitt in the Nation magazine she said
that Pro decriminalization sex work
activists activists like you and Melissa
JIRA grant aren't really representative
of sex workers that you don't really
because you're educated you're public
intellectuals you're bloggers your
writers your authors you don't actually
speak for the typical sex worker but you
pretend to how do you respond to that
well it this is based on the concept
that there is a a sex worker type
there's a specific kind of person who's
a sex worker there isn't we run the
gamut there are every kind of person
that you can imagine meeting in day to
day life can be a sex worker and so to
say that I'm not representative or
Melissa juror is not representative or
or anybody is not is is rather foolish
it's it puts pretending that there is
only one type I'm not any more or less
representative than anybody else so what
types are there I mean when we think of
sex worker we think of in America I
think in American culture we typically
think of a woman working under an
overpass or on Santa Monica Boulevard in
Hollywood at 3:00 in the morning or a
Cambodian peasant is that who they are
no I mean those exists certainly but
that's a minority I would say if I had
to judge the average sex worker now in
the United States okay we're talking
just United States is is probably
middle-class to working class as an
escort she advertises on the Internet
she's independent she doesn't work for
anybody else that's that's probably the
average now that's probably the norm so
numbers you've spent a lot of time on
your blog trying to debunk the numbers
that are commonly thrown around about
sex work so let's talk about some
numbers this is where I think you're
very useful
United States State Department website
right now it says that there are up to
27 million slaves in the world where
does that number come from that number
comes from amending Kevin bales he runs
an organization called free the slaves
and at a conference I can't recall
offhand what kind of a conference it was
some kind of UN thing a few years ago
somebody asked him to to sort of make a
spitballing just guesstimate of how many
there were and he said well if I had to
guess it would probably be like the
third largest criminal enterprise in the
world and of course ever since then
that's been quoted as a ironclad you
know some sort of thing that was derived
1/2 the 27 million number he did by
creating a sort of an algorithm that's
what he calls it anyway
that takes State Department estimates
other things plugs them into a formula
inflates them by what he considers to be
some sort of a number to represent
things that aren't being reported and
multiplies in media reports and of
course the danger of this is that when
you're using media reports in the middle
of a panic your numbers are going to
keep increasing the more people talk
about it the number higher the number of
media reports is I've seen numbers like
30 million 35 million turn around slaves
and also I've seen sort of an implicit
assumption that most of those are sex
slaves first of all what is the real
number here there is no way to know as
long as government's insist on
criminalizing these things how do you
get a number you know nobody's going to
going to come out and talk to in some
places where the criminalization is
particularly bad like in the United
States or in Sweden it's difficult to
even get sex workers to come out and
talk to public health people because
anybody in a white coat anybody with an
official nametag is viewed as working
with the police as working with the
government you're simply not going to be
able to get those kind of numbers my
opinion and this is my opinion only is
that the only numbers I can be even
considered remotely reliable would be
from New Zealand
and to a lesser extent New South Wales
because they have a decriminalized
system there's no reason in those places
for the sex workers to hide
they can't be arrested simply for saying
I'm a sex worker and so I think we can
trust their numbers a little better but
how high do you think the 27 million
figure is I think that's high by
probably at least a couple orders of
magnitude and the reason I say that is
because the Union the UN Office of Drugs
and Crime they're numbers that they use
for but they say that there's evidence
although I can't really how they phrase
it but there's evidence of or that they
consider proven or whatever is one
percent of that we're talking about
people who are allegedly forced into
that prostitution or other forms of link
right correct we're not talking about
voluntary prostitution well that's the
problem the problem is that nobody
defines trafficking trafficking is this
very very broad term technically
supposedly it's supposed to be force
fraud or coercion but that's not the
what happens in practice what happens in
practice is you have things like
government's saying well we're going to
count every one below and this is the
United States we're going to count
everyone below 18 as automatically being
coerced even if they're not oh and you
have things like police I was just
reading an article from Denver it was
not from this year but it was like last
year's article but still where basically
they said the police the policeman being
interviewed for this article said well
they even the ones who think they're not
coerced
they really are coerced and we just have
to convince them that they're coerced
that's our job and so you have these
sorts of things where people will insist
vociferously but they're not being
coerced and the court simply ignore them
New York State now refers all
prostitution courses to what they're
calling trafficking court and that's
what they're calling you've got police
departments that are doing a
straight-out street stinks like they've
done for a century and they're calling
them human trafficking stings now so you
know it how do you get a number when you
have that sort of thing when everybody
has a different definition here's
another number that's used quite often
which is that there are 300,000
trafficked children inside the United
states that is a distortion of SD Neal s
T's no is Richard s DS and Neal whiner I
think is the name s DS and wider anyway
in 2001 they did a study that they
purported to estimate the number of
children adolescents and youth because
their number went up to at least
twenty-one because some of these were
working in strip clubs and such so the
numbers went up to college-age people
and supposedly this is the number that
were at risk of sexual exploitation was
somewhere between 100,000 and 300,000 I
think that they gave a number of 270,000
children are at risk for the fret of
being not children but not just children
because adolescence and youth also but
that was stripped away when people quote
that they change at risk too in
prostitution they change children
adolescents and youth to children and
also the the categories even the
categories of Winer himself when he was
interviewed for a Village Voice story a
couple years ago even said that actual
traffic and what people think of as
trafficking you know abduction and force
would be a very very tiny percentage of
that whole number they included things
like watching porn they included things
like legally working in a strip club
they included consensual homosexual
relations as sexual exploitation so you
know it when you when you have that kind
of a vague you know and then they've
they've narrow it down in the propaganda
to represent something that even the
original people who did the study
weren't intending also many anti
trafficking organizations claimed that
the average age of entry into
prostitution is 13 there's a researcher
Melissa Farley who does an awful lot of
these kind of studies to provide numbers
for the the anti-prostitution people and
on her site she traced this supposed
number of you know average age of 13 to
several old studies which all drew back
to a study done here in LA actually in
the early 80s and 82 and that study
found the average age of entry for
underage sex workers not for all sex
workers but only for underage ones was
about 16 in a different part of the
study they listed 13 as being the
average age of first sexual contact
first kiss first groping in a car first
whatever you know Farley seems to have
conflated the two numbers to represent
that 13 as being the age not of first
sexual contact but at first accepting
money for it even so she still was only
claiming that that was the age of origin
for underage sex workers normal
distortion you know the gossip game
syndrome has changed that from underage
to average of all so let's say that
these numbers are in fact grossly
exaggerated but would you deny that
there are women who are forced into
prostitution and you deny that there are
children who are forced to do it and
then if that's the case then what is the
harm of exaggerating because the
argument that's made is that it draws
attention to a very important problem oh
I'm sure it does I'm sure it does draw
attention it's but the problem is that
these these false numbers these inflated
numbers are invariably linked to
purported solutions that aren't
solutions at all
greater criminalization the so called
end demand which is the idea of pursuing
clients and the the pretense that sex
workers are not being targeted when they
still are they're just being targeted
extra judicially in the United States
it's it's really kind of absurd to even
claim that oh we're only targeting the
clients when all the the law is against
sex work against sale of sex you're
still in the books you know they're so
how can you claim more only targeting
the clients and what we just won't
charge sex workers when we don't feel
like it when you look at the language
that's used in the media reports
especially with these FBI innocence lost
that sort of thing they'll use the term
rescue and of course rescue means arrest
[ __ ] means jailing them in some places
it might mean putting them into some
sort of you know facility some sort of a
foster type facility in other places
just means plain jail and they're
calling this rescue because the the
premise they seem to be proceeding from
is the idea being in jail is better for
these for these girls and it's always
girls even though young male sex workers
do exist an adult male sex workers do
exist but that's not part of the
narrative so is it safe to say that the
organizations and individuals who push
these numbers are generally not in favor
of decriminalizing that's correct okay
yeah that's correct
let's talk about Somali mom who was
recently revealed as essentially
perpetrating a fraud that she she
claimed that she had been sold into sex
slavery in Cambodia she established a
very popular NGO in Cambodia that was a
big cause celeb of many American
celebrities she had women working for
whom she claimed were also sold into sex
slavery and that is all and I think
shown to be a fraud now that she okay so
let's say that's true that it is a fraud
what harm did what what harm did Somali
mom do well for one thing again it's the
same as what we just were saying that
when you tie these stories to an agenda
and there was a very definite agenda as
in Somali mom's case the the agenda in
her case was she would have these joint
raids with the police she would get the
police to raid brothels to go in and
arrest again and the all women working
there they would lie about the ages they
would claim that they were younger than
they were generally there then
incarcerated in either her so-called
rehabilitation centers or in plain jails
where they are subjected to basically
the same sort of harsh awful treatment
that sex workers are often subjected to
at the hands of the police the world
round so the what the harm is is you
when you have a narrative that is being
used
directly to justify horrible abusive
treatment
I'd say that's a problem so I was
reading an interview in Vice recently of
an anti-trafficking hero in India I
forget her name but who runs a
rehabilitation a rehabilitation center
for allegedly trafficked women and she
was asked what happened inside her
rehabilitation centers and she refused
to answer that what typically does
happen inside those centers it's funny
you asked that because just a couple of
weeks ago I do every OMA in my blog I do
a guest blog once a month and my last
one for May was by a young Indian sex
worker who now lives in London but when
she was very young
actually before she even started sex
work but she had friends who were sex
workers and she was caught up in a raid
and imprisoned in one of these these
centers and she explained what does
happen and well there's a lot of
physical abuse in the arrest process of
course the same as arrest the world over
but then once they're there in the the
center the main function is for them to
their reason for being there is to
justify the existence of the NGO is to
justify the NGO continuing to get money
one of the ways they do that is by
prosecution they have to prosecute
so-called traffickers and so they need
the girls to serve as as witnesses so
they keep the girls against their will
as witnesses in these rehabilitation
centers while the so-called traffickers
pay their bail and go home and the girls
can be kept in India for this example
we're using this the court system is
very slow this can be years that they're
sitting in these rehab centers they're
basically treated very poorly and
whenever the rich American ladies come
to see what their money is paying for
they're trotted out to give a show like
trained dogs to give a show for them for
the white ladies that are coming to see
the the young woman that wrote the the
guest column for me told me that she was
hidden away whenever these donors came
because she could speak some English and
so they basically lock her up in her
room because they only wanted the girls
who couldn't speak English so that they
couldn't interact in any meaningful way
with the donors and tell them things I
didn't want to hear so you like many
activists insist on using the term sex
work instead of prostitution why is that
I'm probably less rigid with it then a
lot of others I'm pretty much used
whatever term I think that the person's
comfortable with but sex work is the
preferred term in the movement the
reason for this is because there is a
very common form of rhetoric that's used
against us and this it's been forever
that sex work isn't work that it is a
dodge that it's a scam that it's a form
of exploitation that it's a that it's a
lazy approach to making money that it's
I mean you fill in the blank anything
other than giving it the dignity of work
and as a matter of fact one one of their
little mantras that you often hear the
prohibition is spouting these days as
prostitution is not the oldest
profession it's the oldest oppression so
again the when you strip away its
characters work then you take then you
basically are trying to derail the
argument of workers rights you're trying
to derail you know we don't question
that McDonald's for example or or the
garment industry or or the the Apple the
iPad Factory you know we don't question
that these things have a right to exist
even people who are fighting against
what they perceive as abuses in these
industries don't question that the
industry itself should exist but in sex
work because it's cast as not work they
pretend that it has no right to exist at
all and so there's these ideas of
abolishing it getting rid of it entirely
in nobody's talking about abolishing
fast food nobody's talking about
abolishing iPad well I think the
argument more commonly is that it's a
special form of exploitation that it's
an especially intimate form of
exploitation that you find in no other
form of work how do you respond to that
argument there's a lot of work that's
intimate isn't there I mean what about
raising people's children you know but
in America we don't have a problem
handing our children over to complete
strangers to raise them and daycares or
nannies what about therapy I mean you're
telling this this person things that you
might not even tell your best friend you
might not even tell your spouse what
about nursing I have friends who are
nurses and they they have to you know
clean people's intimate parts and things
like that
my gynecologist gets pretty intimate
with my my private parts you know when
she examines me so the fact of something
being intimate I don't think that's an
argument that's either here nor there as
long as both parties agree I can't see
where the relative level of intimacy and
what is intimacy anyway when you really
get down to it I mean who defines that I
think that the the two parties involved
are the only ones that have a right to
define is it there's a common assumption
very common assumption in our culture
that that kind of work is damaging to
women that selling their bodies for
money it constitutes some sort of damage
to them psychologically spiritually
morally physically that they can never
really recover from what do you think
about that well it's positively
Victorian isn't it I mean it goes back
to to lie back and think of England it's
the idea that women are not sexual
beings that women are intrinsically
asexual that we're only sexual that we
can only be sexual under certain
conditions that it's almost like some
sort of radio you know radioactive
material or something that we can only
be sexual if it's it's wrapped in in
pretty bows and ribbons and and it has
the sanctity of the church on it and we
call it marriage and we give you the
special certificate or you're only doing
it because you love the person or you
know all these sorts of things and and
this is absurd this is this is not what
feminism was supposed to be but this is
what we've come back around to we've
grown to these again very Victorian
notions that a woman is damaged by sex a
woman is hurt by sex
that what a woman is raped for example
that her life will never be the same
again that she's ruined you know they
used to call it a fate worse than death
and I think that this is NIC that this
is an intrinsically anti-feminist view
because it gives a tremendous tremendous
power to men really because what you're
saying is that a man has this almost
magical power to destroy a woman's life
merely by touching her in the wrong way
what about katha pollitt Sarg you meant
that prostitution is an industry in
which men's desires are catered to
therefore it is essentially patriarchal
well people's desires are catered to in
restaurants people's doesn't mean it is
any name business if you don't cater to
the client you don't get business I
think she's trying to show a square peg
in a round hole there I don't think a
business can be patriarchal per se I
mean maybe some people might disagree
with me maybe there's some sort of a
Marxist interpretation that says
otherwise but to me the principle of
voluntary exchange is is is neutral is
gender neutral I don't really see a case
I mean I suppose an argument can be made
but I've never seen one that I found
it's a desire like any other in a
shortcut exchange so if there is a
problem with involuntary sex work which
would be trafficking or slavery what
should be done then do you want to do
nothing about it let the market take its
course
no no I wouldn't go back that far the
problem is that they already are laws
for these things we have a name for sex
being inflicted on a woman against her
will we call it rape we have a name for
taking someone and holding them prisoner
some would call it abduction these
things are already against the law we
have you know against a boss taking
wages that don't belong to him we call
that theft these things are all against
the law already why do we need this new
construct and vain construct there is
even properly defined why do we need
this to be laid on top of all these
other things that already are crimes and
the answer of course is because
it isn't the involuntary that they
really care about the prohibitionist
don't care about the involuntary I think
that there are some of them maybe that
are deluded enough to think that this is
common but I think the majority of them
know better I think the majority know
quite well that what they're actually
targeting is consensual sex work by
redefining it as non-consensual and to
redefine it as non-consensual once again
we have to go back to that idea that a
woman doesn't have agency over her own
body but a woman that choices a woman
makes where sex is involved
automatically suspect that really that
essentially in the area of sex that a
woman is a permanent adolescent because
when you look at things like the Swedish
model you know this this it's becoming
very popular in United States and Canada
is now trying to impose it this idea
that only the client should be
criminalized
what is this resemble most closely what
it resembles most closely to me is
statutory rape laws the idea that the
woman is not that her consent is
immaterial that the male is essentially
her moral superior and so he needs to be
held accountable and whether she agreed
or whether she didn't agree is
completely immaterial so what is it
about sex here what why is sex work seen
as a sort of separate entirely separate
category of work why is it stigmatized
in the way that it I think it's just sex
I think sex is just the same reason
sexist what does that say about our
culture and its view of sex I think this
is a very ancient thing isn't it I mean
you know sex in ancient times was
different it was the only thing that
could produce a human being and I think
what's happened is that we simply
haven't caught up we simply haven't
matured we simply haven't recognized
that birth control and abortion make
this not so there's not necessarily a
chance when a woman has sex that a life
could result maybe back in ancient times
when that was true maybe they were right
in those days to think of sex as being a
special case because it could produce a
baby and that's something important but
not now a woman who doesn't want to get
pregnant now doesn't have to but yet we
still pretend that it's a special case
we still pretend that
there's a magical mumbo-jumbo taboo you
know energy about sacks that makes it
different from all other human
activities and this is something that I
simply don't see so why should it be
decriminalized the the decriminalization
I think has nothing to do with the sex
argument I think the decriminalization
the best argument for decriminalization
is a harm reduction argument which is
simply that all the other forms of
managing it cause more harm than good
criminalization certainly does the
Swedish model certainly does even the
so-called legalization regimes you know
what we have here in Nevada you know we
the the idea that you can only do sex
work if you're doing it for somebody
else in a specific place far from where
good people can see it way out in the
desert only in small counties and then
only connected cronies can get the
licenses so this is this is not a good
saying that if a woman chooses to work
in a brothel that that's bad I mean is
if that's her choice that's her choice
what I'm saying is that the choice
shouldn't be taken away and in a
legalized system which are saying is
that choice is taken away but what's
particularly bizarre to me is that you
can cross a border and the the rules of
legalization change completely
so in Nevada the only form of sex work
allowed is in a brothel in Canada
brothels are illegal you can only do it
if you're not working for someone else
same thing with the English Channel
right in the Netherlands brothels are
legal in Britain they're not legal and
what New Zealand did and what New South
Wales in Australia did is they both
recognized that when you when you want
to start making regulations and laws and
rules about sex mark you get into some
very deep thickets very fast because
then you get into things like what is
prostitution if if a man gives me an
expensive present and I and I have sex
with him for this expensive present is
that prostitution if he pays me a
lot rate per month and I have sex with
them is that prostitution and you get
into these these things like that and
what New Zealand and New South Wales
both realized is that these rules when
you start asking police to make these
judgments they will always judge on the
side of criminalization they will always
judge in the side of arrest if there's
an ambiguous situation they're going to
just arrest everybody and to stop that
you need to just take this the police
out of it entirely seems like at the end
of the day it's not a legal question
it's a cultural question it sounds like
from what you're saying that as a
culture we need to think differently
about sex before we have a solution to
this we have to grow up I mean it's that
simple we need to grow up the idea that
if you if they find out that a hotel
room was being used by a sex worker that
that contaminates the hotel room because
of some sort of magical you taboo energy
that goes into it this is silly this is
childish this is not something for the
21st century for the most
technologically advanced nation on earth
to be still practicing and yet we do so
yeah I think that's what it is I think
we just need to grow up well thank you
Maggie for joining us this has been
great for recent TV unfabulous on